efectivamente salud global y economía
recordemos centrada en la crisis del cob
y 19 y en la crisis económica derivada
de la crisis sanitaria la idea
justamente de las potencias más ricas
del planeta del g20 es enfatizar en la
solidaridad en lo que son las vacunas y
segundo un trascendido de lo que va a
ser ese borrador final de este g-20 los
países se habrían comprometido a que de
aquí al año 2022 un 70 por ciento de la
población esté vacunada y de aquí a fin
de año un 50 por ciento de recordemos
las cifras que han circulado en las
últimas horas en los países ricos un 60
por ciento de la población ha tenido
acceso a dos dosis de vacunas sin
embargo esa cifra cae a un 4,5 por
ciento y una dosis de vacuna en el caso
de los países pobres también que hubo de
novedad en esta reunión la participación
virtual de rusia y china dos países
cuyas vacunas no son reconocidas
masivamente los países occidentales
justamente ese fue el pedido de xi
jinping y de vladimir putin que sus
vacunas sean reconocidas recordemos por
ejemplo que la unión europea estas
vacunas no son oficiales aunque ya hay
varios países que han comenzado a
aceptarlas para que las personas puedan
ingresar sobre todo los turistas a sus
países otra novedad de este trascendido
que ha habido sobre ese borrador final
el que las vacunas se desarrollen en
apenas algunas semanas recordemos que
hasta ahora se desarrollaban en décadas
pues bien se autoriza que menos de 100
días una vacuna pueda estar disponible
para atacar un tipo de pandemia como la
que hemos vivido valentina erika y al
margen tiene lugar una reunión entre el
presidente joe biden y los líderes
europeos boris johnson emanuel mccomb
ian y angela merkel en torno al programa
nuclear iraní que detalles se conocen de
este encuentro
efectivamente de valentina también esa
reunión ya terminó es lo que tiene el
g20 están los presidentes de los países
más ricos del mundo y más poderosos
también y por lo tanto hay muchas
reuniones laterales una importante tiene
que ver con ese programa nuclear de irán
recordemos que dura el año 2018 donald
trump sacó a eeuu de este acuerdo lo que
dejó en letra muerta ese acuerdo que se
había encontrado en el año 2015 entre
irán y el grupo 5 más 1 sin embargo
ahora con el regreso de los demócratas y
joe biden a la cabeza de la casa blanca
la idea es retomar las negociaciones
ojalá a fines de noviembre por lo tanto
los países occidentales querían juntarse
para ver cuáles van a ser los requisitos
que se impongan a la república islámica
estas negociaciones tenían toda la cara
de comenzar había un impulso muy grande
sin embargo en junio hubo elecciones en
este país y ganó el conservador ebrahim
raisi que ha dicho que quiere primero
evaluar lo que ha pasado las antiguas
conversaciones antes de volverse a
sentar con las potencias occidentales
erika pues muchas gracias por esta
ampliación estamos muy pendientes de lo
que pueda ocurrir en las próximas horas